Now you can do this with existing files on your
computer, but if you want to follow along this example,
feel free to download the zip file in the instructor
notes. When you unzip that file, you'll have a folder
much like this one, with about 50 photos. Okay, so
what I've done thus far is just created a new
file in Idle, and I called it rename_files.py. And inside
that, I've created an empty function by the same name.
Then I added comments of the two main things I have to do in my program. By the
way, notice that the function right now is pretty
empty, and if I saved and ran the program, it
would essentially do nothing. The first thing I have
to do, is get the file names from a given
folder. So Google can help with that. Let me
just type in Find file names in a folder in
Python. Now I read through the results, and
I got to this stack overflow.com page. And here
I read that there is this thing called os.listdir,
which will get you everything that's in a given
directory. Now it turns out that there is a
module in Python called os, short for operating system.
And that has a function inside it called listdir.
Which, as its name suggests, lists everything that's in
a given directory. So let's add this to the
code and see what it does. Now this function listdir
takes in a path of the folder that contains our
photos. So I'll go back to my folder. Copy its
address, and paste it. Now for those of you who
are on a Mac, you can use a document in
the instructor notes, that will help you get the path
of your folder. On a Windows machine however, right before
where the path begins, I will add this
letter r, and r stands for rawpack, and it
tells Python hey, take this string as it
is, and don't interpret it any other way. So
here let me just save this in a variable, and print that out. Let me save, and
then run, and oh wow, we get a list of all of the file names inside that folder.
It's an ugly looking list, but a list
nonetheless. Alright, step one of the program is done.